einhörner gefunden und so was alles also
das finde ich ist so alles so mehr oder
weniger so könig der löwen ist also
dieser zieht auch diese diese lava
stelle wo beispielsweise der faser der
faser könig waren alles den bach runter
gegangen ist war sehr hier oben am abend
an diesem stein
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren zieht vorstellung in der
minecraft 1.7.2011 vorstellen der euch
dass wir als nummer tafelberg biom
tafelberg bio meta meta meta meta oder
mäßig werde ich glaube es heißt mega ich
bin mir da eigentlich ganz schön neue
sicherheit so sagt nix jahr sieht es -
840 222 844 129 37 91 85
diese ganzen zahlenkombinationen mensch
da ich krieg die krise dabei und dieses
bio möchte ich einfach nur vorstellen
weil es ist nichts besonderes da also es
ist jetzt nicht irgendwie ganz
besonderes billionen tafelberg findet
man schon ein bisschen öfter als öfter
ist auch schon eher seltener aber es ist
auf jeden fall mal da und es ist auch
nicht so etwas besonders wie in der
ersten vorstellung die ich von der
minecraft 1.7 gemacht habe wo nämlich
was waren da noch mal was von meiner
ersten acht oder zweimal dieser survival
sieht sondern es erinnert mich einfach
an könig der löwen
es ist für mich ein könig der löwen seed
ich finde es ist einfach ein könig der
löwen zieht weil das erinnert mich
einfach ein könig der löwen kennt die
könig der löwen diesen diesen diesem
felsen wo ich habe alle filme geguckt
damals ganz oft im auto partner wie
könig der löwen geguckt schreibt mir
dass meine kommentare kennt ihr könig
der löwen also eigentlich müsstet ihr
das kennen und wenden und wenn ja habt
ihr das damit auch mal so mit euren
eltern geguckt oder so die teile also
ich hab das zum beispiel mal gemacht
weil dieses diese bio mit ihren könig
der löwen
weil irgendwie da ich weiß nicht es war
halt immer so es gab dieses land der
dieses punkte dunkle land diese dunkle
weite und das jetzt zum beispiel für
mich finde ich also man sonntag direkt
hier
das ist für mich zu dieser platz so wo
nahla und simba und jahr also die ganzen
löwen
so diese diese diese diese wasserstelle
wo als ich rede von der story so ein
bisschen ich möchte das mal so ein
bisschen anders machen und zwei hat mich
dieser sieht einfach daran wo nahla und
chiara und simba glaube ich also es ist
ein kinderfilm könig der löwen mich
jetzt auf mein kind halbzeit nach wo die
gesagt haben dass sie da hingehen und so
was alles also das ist für mich so diese
diese löwen löwen und löwen wasserstelle
wo diese allemal so rum la hier das
sieht so aus und wo diese linie nicht
dass ihr aber das hier unten sieht so
aus wo silber sowie heißt immer der
vater von simba wie heißt der vater mo
fr sa neben vater ist der böse mufasa
und der andere heißt wie heißt noch mal
sind was vater schreibt mir dass man den
kommentare wir jetzt etwas vater dass er
nämlich hier an so ein bisschen so wie
diese in denen sie verfolgt haben wir
das so schluchten mäßig hier sind zu
diesem wen er gelaufen wenn der boden
hier auch noch aus soll material wegen
besonders real invest perfekt hier sind
zu diesen hergelaufen und die sind so
sind bei hinterher gelaufen und hätten
den so überrollt und musste sind was
vater den so retten
dabei sind was vater halt drauf gegangen
mut hat so getan als ob der so total
einfühlsam wer aber fahren er gar nicht
weil er total böse und so und am ende
ist auch da sondern sein einfluss und
das ist er jetzt also hier zum becken
aber naja da weil sein team eine und ich
finde einfach so diese städte nennen
wenn jetzt noch löwen werden oder so ich
glaube in hexe sind ja in exit habe ich
auf jeden fall mit tadel habe ich in
hexe die einhörner gefunden und so was
alles also das finde ich ist so alles so
mehr oder weniger so könig der löwen
style zu dieser zieht auch diese diese
lava stelle wo beispielsweise die faser
der volvofahrer könig waren alles den
bach runter gegangen ist war sehr hier
oben am an diesem stein und hat dazu
runter geguckt dabei war halt lava und
feuer und alles und das hier ist so
außer dass verbotenen land zu mehr oder
weniger hast du alles so dunkel gehalten
auch wenn dieser erde und so und hier
auch wieder so schluchten und so was
alles also es ist für mich wirklich
einfachen könig der löwen ist diese
ganzen ich liebe einfach diese farben
ich liebe das tafelberg bio das ist das
allerletzte was minecraft je passiert
ist ein bio mit solchen also wollen wir
immer so knallige farben aber das hier
wirklich zu trübe farben
mag ich einfach solche farben sind
einfach hammergeil oder auch wie gesagt
dieses dieses orange und auch dieses rot
das sind so hat das hier ist einfach
dieser sand aber dieses rot und dieses
orange was man hier zum beispiel hat das
intel orange gefärbt der leben und rot
gefärbter denen das sind so die
schönsten blöcke dies gibt in minecraft
das sind so die schönsten sachen die es
gibt deswegen was ich euch übrigens auch
noch fragen wollte also ihr habt mir das
wahrscheinlich gerade mit dem vater eine
kommentare geschrieben
das ist echt peinlich dass da gar nicht
aufkommen obwohl es damit mein
lieblingsfilm war was ich euch auch noch
fragen wollte jetzt an alle die jetzt
bis zum ende da sind ihr seid ja dann so
die treuen zuschauer die sich alles dann
immer so angucken
erstmal habe ich liebe dich zweite sache
wollt ihr mal dass ich so eine serie
machen wo ich immer so top drei sachen
vorstellen es gibt ja top 10
den sollte eigentlich alle kennen top
youtube.com / pop szene macht richtig
geile videos jetzt stellt immer so top10
future entwicklungen vor top zehn beste
filme oder irgend sowas ich wollte das
so hauptsächlich in minecraft machen und
zwar top 3 halt immer so weil sie nicht
meine top drei lieblings blöcke die ich
finde diese am besten aussehen wie jetzt
gerade zum beispiel oder sowas wie die
top drei songs die songs die ich am
besten finden die minecraft gemacht
wurden oder auch sowas so die top-3
snapshot updates die idee gekommen sind
solche ganzen sachen und die top drei
videos die ich zum beispiel von mir die
ich dann zu minecraft gemacht habt ist
am besten finde sowas zu minecraft
bezogen wollt ihr sowas dann gibt
einfach mal daumen hoch und schreibt das
vor allem in der kommentare irgendwie so
ja wir wollen top drei sachen und so was
alles damit ihr seht was ich so feier in
minecraft beziehungsweise um minecraft
herum oder wollte so was nicht dann gibt
einfach ein daumen runter und schreibt
einfach du bist behindert nein ich
möchte so was nicht
oder schreibt einfach was konstruktives
und wir sind wieder bei fünfeinhalb
minuten bei dieser vorstellung deswegen
würde ich sagen ja wie gesagt schreib
mir im konklave wir sind bei mir wieder
macht's gut rein und ciao